気づいたのは最近でした
僕たちはご飯を食べに行こうと思い
何気なく家の周りの道を歩いていました
家の近くまで来ると、ある異変に私は気づいたのです
！？！？！？！？
どうした はじめさん？
なんだよコレ（指さす
無数の手形が私の家の壁に残っていたのです
付いていた手形はとても高い位置に付いていて とても人間一人では届かない場所に・・・付いていました。
僕たちはドン引きして・・・うん ドン引きしただけでした
こんにちは はじめしゃちょーです
今見ていただいた動画 まぁ あくまでイメージ動画何ですけど・・・ガチです
手の跡も本物でございます
な！！ まさき（大きな声で呼びかける
まさき：は～い
はじめ：あれガチだよね？
まさき：ガチ
ガチなんすよ
逆に逆に 僕がヤラセでするなら「血」の跡とかつけてやります
なんの話。
誰がやったかわからない けどおそらくなんですけども　誰かが僕の家によじ登ろうとしてたのかな？ という予想をしております。
いやマジ怖かったっすよ
実際あれを見たときマジ怖かったですから
誰、誰 誰なの
！！誰！！
え、だって この動画を見てる誰かがかもしれませんからね
て、ほぼその確率が高い
君？
君なの？
この動画を見てる誰かがひょっとしてぼくんち～に 着てよじ登ろうとしてぼくんちに侵入しようとした ってゆう 事がありました
まさきさん怖くないっすか？
まさき：ホントに怖い
はじめ：結構笑えなくない？
まさき：うん
そので、あの、手形が付いてた場所なんですけども
あれ 多分 僕が本気でジャンプしてもとどかない場所です
実際に飛んでみたんですけども まず あの高さにとどかない
なん、なん、なに
はしごとか使ったんかね？
はしごか 何かに乗ってジャンプしたり よじ登ったりしてたのかな って気はしてます
いゃ、笑い事じゃないってホント
ほんとほんと 笑えないからね
結構 怖いからね！
あのー・・・やめてくださいね
知らない人が家に来られるの 怖いことです
うちの建物よじ登ろうとするのは やめてください
て ゆうね 最近マジでぞっとしたし 凄いこわかったな
って お話がしたかったです
そんだけ！！
-再現VTR撮影中-